[Music]
so
no
don't believe it
uh
[Music]
[Music]
in the streets
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey a little bit ago a tiger claw called
for help attacked by a certain aki at
least that's what they call the rogue
tiger hunter he's been picking off his
own in silent but spectacular fashion
my gut says this aki had a
cyberpsychotic break
but i'd like to know for sure
don't kill him if you don't have to and
don't forget to watch your back
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
zero
the hell is this
now you [ __ ]
god
again
we lost everything
[Music]
uh you're here
that's nova
get in take you for a ride
as soon as i saw you that time thought
to myself
those are some balls on that one
and i definitely need someone with a
pair for this job never mind your
testicles tell them to keep those hands
at ten and two
always wound up in a ditch whenever
kerry drove
these are wheels god no come on
borrowed it
so no loss if we wreck it that's the
plan
[ __ ] knew it
so what good will my balls do us today
some people in this town
they've gone completely whacked
you
you're gonna help me set things right in
this [ __ ] we call home
uh-huh
how's that exactly there's this little
girl group us cracks right three birds
from japan
laser pop scop
yeah big over in asia i mean
who is it
now they signed some deal for an nus
tour
wanna promote it with a cover of my song
can you believe that
not about to let them play me like that
[Music]
right
so
what's the plan
the truck with the us cracks kid will be
coming this way
we do it old style like last century
we blow the [ __ ] up
no gear those [ __ ] will have to
cancel concerts
carrie solving his own problems
he used to just send in an army of
lawyers
they made it all disappear while he
tanned his bare ass by the pool
must be some [ __ ] indeed
be there in a second
[Music]
here we are
[Music]
trunk
grab what's in there
well well
quite the
arsenal we're fighting for art art with
a capital a
come on get to work
i know the guy
this ain't about art
you got it
you know they killed ivy coma right here
in this very spot
dj
cloaked av followed her limo
almost nothing left of her afterwards or
a limo
turned out later she wasn't the target
some biotechnica suit busy eating her
out when the bullets started flying
found the bodies
just like that
lay it out here
right
hi quick
[Music]
we know
now we wait
all right just spit it out
this is set up
flocka media is about to fly in
wouldn't mind that actually
honestly
no idea what's about to go down
just
improvise
there she is
right on the dots
i take the driver you get his sideshow
we want him out of the truck
what are you doing the hell was that
out of the truck on the ground and i can
see him
get out ground now
hey man listen on the ground i said
hey man lose the iron
let's talk it out not a word
all be over soon
ah [ __ ] now
access card grab it
pop the back
quit squirming and no gunk moves
calm and quiet it'll be over
soon what's inside
stuff's worth at least a couple hundred
thousand
really want to trash it not clep it
please
never stolen a thing in my life
[ __ ] me he really believes that
i remember all my strings getting swept
back in the day never had his arm
right gents now run along and don't look
back
i said
delta the [ __ ] off
now for the grand finale i want this set
to be a smoldering puddle of chrome and
plastic when we're done
you're the boss
lighter up
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah
good working with you b
[ __ ] me carrie
meaning it's just a truck of toys for
some plastic japanese dolls
might as well blow up a cotton candy
stand
but
still a big step forward
i hardly recognize the bastard
burning real nice i'll grant you that
thing is
i mean
what's it actually get you
those little [ __ ] think they can make
it big on my song
they got another thing coming
you even know what i had to sacrifice to
get where i am the price i paid for
success
and those 10 annie [ __ ] want to clip
my tune and expect me to just let them
[ __ ] pig ignorant hacks
yeah success
always a sore spot of cares
see nothing's changed
but wouldn't it have been better to have
a lawyer fight this fight for you
oh you're one to talk i'll flash my
teeth and sign papers enough for one
lifetime
this here
i'm sending a message
this is how you do biz in night city
cops that's delta
you try get him off our ass
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
last time i ran from the cops back in
2020 with johnny actually
high out of our damn minds pigs still
could catch us
[Music]
these gogs don't stand a chance
[ __ ] pigs
yeah well don't pop the champagne yet
still riding our asses
quicker the better too i'm starving
come on [ __ ]
[Music]
lost him
paying off the ass for you but it was
worth every eddie nice one
yeah to see a single eddie
okay drop me off i can't eat this
[Music]
[Music]
gary uridine eats at a dump like this
jumbata
best coffee in town right here thickest
tar and if they know you they give you
the getting stuff
come on my treat
wow
coffee with a rock star now why not
first time for everything
when samurai started out we spent every
annie we had on guitars strings you know
hey rachel
good morning
know this dump
know that smell
but how
hi you were looking for someone
ah almost nothing left over for food
but we still went across the street
every day right to caliente
stuffed our faces
down joe by the gallon
johnny said we were so hungry and high
we would have eaten the cardboard boxes
out from under the bums outside
of course he was wrong
the usual mr eurodine
double espresso jamaican blend nothing
else no sugar
you got it and for you
what he's having
great be right back with it
oh
[ __ ]
just coming down now
whoo
[ __ ] awesome
last time i felt like this was back in
memphis
last tour
last concert vibes from the crowd me on
stage
oh [ __ ]
just thought about those us cracks [ __ ]
again
you think we got him
say this much they don't back out now
give me a call we'll convince him
another way
thanks
hope they're off my sonar now cause if
not
[ __ ] last thing i want is johnny to have
been right all along
johnny's dead
so they say
you're alive
decide whose truth matters to you more
yours or someone else's
that a trick question
only if you don't have the nads to
answer it honestly
better be going
thanks for uh
you know
don't mention it
[Music]
oh
[Music]
has it really come to this
night city
[Music]
[Music]
b
got a guy i need gun
used to be iron for hire still acts like
it
but the eddies are worth the risk trust
me
the more intel check the attachment
waiting on your scene thanks
think fleas like you just get in for
free
you have vip rooms here you know for
private shindigs
reserved for the boston call think he
could use a little more company
don't try to play me either i see
eddie's or your ass is walking
just chill already here
sweet jesus you hear that do you hear
what they're playing
each to their own johnny
that's what peeps with bad taste always
say
don't know what he did to deserve what's
coming but his music taste is reason
enough to drop it
uh
hey how's it going how rude
music in here is god awful
yeah i like it
beet keeps me awake
want to have a word with your boss
tian
oh
you're out of luck
he doesn't really like the dog
i don't care if he likes to talk i asked
you if he was here
uh sure he's upstairs in the vip room
just don't expect a friendly welcome
i wanna have a word
yeah and i wanna snort lines off of
lizzy wheezy shrek
[Music]
oh the who the [ __ ] are you how'd you
get in here quiet down or i'll have to
cut our convo short oh i get it got a
bounty on my head have i
who hides you
milotech asukaga or wasn't that wanker
dino
yeah like sit down jack i'm extending
the [ __ ] courtesy here the fact that
you're still alive means i'm open to
partly
paulie vu go [ __ ] yourself
chitchat's for [ __ ] so let's get it
over and done with you versus me come on
say you win
say you put me out of commission you
think your problems will just vanish
into thin air
you crawled under a lot of people's skin
said so yourself
militech asukaga dino they won't stop
till your head falls at their feet
so what i'm supposed to blow my [ __ ]
brains out
no
all you have to do is leave night city
i'll tell him you took lead between the
eyes and none will be the wiser you can
start over a brand new life
yeah
start with what
everything i got's here my club
staff my girls and everyone who wants
you dead
this isn't a multiple [ __ ] choice
you're living on borrowed time
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bleeding [ __ ] [ __ ] was
that a yes or a no just piss off and
tell him the job's done
fly
ah
another murder outside your bedroom
window
[Applause]
for a chance to win
palace
ammonium
what the
[Music]
tommy
ah
yes
[Music]
heard whispers monster bit the concrete
nicely done gig's sealed
your boy dino needs a drink later feet
[Applause]
[Music]
you